[Music]
there is some bombshell news happening
right now
bombshell biden
sun has agreed hunter biden has recently
made headlines
with some crazy photos online and some
crazy emails online
recently been leaked
what photos so i don't know too much
about the story i know about the story
about the story
where there's a lot of people that have
been trying to post like try to get this
public but facebook and twitter have
been silencing all of those things yeah
that's the only thing i've heard about
it
there's a lot of different stories about
this story so what if we get silenced on
the youtube why are we doing this
because the truth needs to come out
patreon
he's ready to fight about it patreon
exclusive yeah
what's the point then
wait all right so long story short
uh short story long please rudy okay
sure
rudy giuliani who is uh trump's lawyer
uh
republican foreign former mayor of new
york city great teeth
great teeth uh recently came and
got a hold of a broken laptop a
recovered laptop of hunter biden wow
and that's the story that's interesting
employee from from
ex-apple employee yes so i know that
much the guys
the guy that actually gave the laptop
handed over to the fbi into rudy
giuliani giuliani is
his name is john paul mcisaac and he is
a former apple genius bar
guy and now he runs his own mac shop and
sometime last year in april uh hunter
biden comes in
with three laptops three broken laptops
he actually walked into the apple shop
himself wow so he's all like yo i don't
know what's up with these things man
i've been like have you been checking
out porn now but i got all these viruses
and [ __ ]
like and there was mad porn in these
these laptops too by the way
there was there was yeah a lot of porn
all right so here are the things that
this guy found right
this guy mick isaac he found a lot of
porn
a lot of uh personal photos like family
photos and stuff like stuff that you
would typically
think you would find in a politician's
son's uh
laptop not in the same files right none
so it's not like
he's hiding it's true he said that the
laptops were
the mess one of the messiest laptops
he's ever come across boulders
everywhere yeah
nothing systematically so it's either
bart's laptop or yours
yeah my laptop's pretty bad yeah porn
everywhere not quite
um i don't keep porn what kind of
categories are we talking about porn
though
i don't know about the porn the
political stuff political porn
yeah like democrat [ __ ] republican i
thought that's what the story was about
was the contents of the pornography two
democrats one independent
he was into that sarah palin poll
remember when that one came out oh sarah
portland
there was a sarah palin porn yeah
everyone's had glasses it was a porn
star that looked like sarah palin
oh interesting what photos are these
bombshell things though like
so yeah so there's a lot of like just
you know your your your typical photos
nice photos of the family and all that
stuff and then there were these photos
and this is can we get to see this this
is where uh
this is where um what's his face uh
twitter this is where twitter
started censoring uh uh these photos so
twitter sensors photos how did you get
them
i know since when there's so much porn
on twitter it's crazy all right so here
are some photos of
hunter biden so this wasn't on his
laptop this is a a
a yeah dude he looks like steve perel
so this is a normal photo of hunter
binding if you didn't know what hunter
biden looked like this is him
and then there are these photos here
this is the photo that was recovered
from the laptop vacation hunter
vacation hunter smoking a cigarette
what's bad what's that so edgy
nothing nothing nothing like typical
like
like typically bad about it but then
there was this photo also what does that
look like in his mouth oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] dude he's a crackhead a
pipe
it's a pipe yeah but it's not just any
type of pie this is the kind of pipe you
wouldn't
you would probably smoke crack with yeah
that's that's the crackpot oh my god
the last the the debate trump was
talking about his
sons in cocaine and he got kicked out of
the new like
uh military and all that stuff yeah yeah
yeah right he was talking about this
photo
i don't know so um there are a lot of
other
contents that haven't been released yet
by rudy giuliani and
giuliani's pretty much saying like i'm
going to slow roll this out
and obviously this is somewhat of a
smear campaign by the republicans
just somewhat yes just a little bit and
um
he's trying to slow roll everything out
so there's a lot more incriminating uh
uh photos here uh including a sex tape
there's an unidentified woman in one of
these photos do you have a sex tape on
there
i do not have the sex tape it's a slow
roll i mean maybe maybe by the time this
video comes out maybe the sex tape is
floating around somewhere in the
upcoming month is going to be very
interesting it's going to be very
interesting for the biden camp yes
so i don't know about sex tapes being
all that wrong i mean like it
got kim kardashian parent hills
periscope we got a lot of people
true yeah if kim kardashian can have a
sex tape and then kanye go i'm going to
be president
then hunters hunters hunter biden can
have a sex tape and then his dad can be
like i'm going to be playing the
crafting
is kind of bad though yeah i have to say
the crack thing is pretty bad isn't it
already known that he had drug issues so
like why is this so like
what yeah and how old was this again
this
is photo i don't know no one's going
these photos aren't dated so i don't
know
but you're right he has come out he's
he's publicly come out and said i've
been dealing with drug addiction and all
these things too so you're right it's
not as crazy as
it's kind of like the melania thing too
it's like where's the big deal
it's a smear campaign it's like it's
it's human nature we all have dark sides
and all that stuff
about ourselves and we don't want the
public to know about but you know it's
there and
i don't have a crack right now is hunter
is he a politician or it's literally the
whole campaign is about your son who's
attached to
you if we can make him look bad then
by association makes you look bad right
and that's a great question because
hunter biden
to my knowledge is uh not a politician
but he has recently in the last uh
couple of years been and
uh been working with the ukrainian
company power uh
as an oil company or something like that
is that why is that
russia is supposed to be our enemy but
then through ukraine he's working
with russia so ukraine is basically well
the um what do you call it the the the
middle man
the middle yeah yeah wait so wasn't one
of the trump kids
also getting in trouble for having some
sort of relationship with russia the
last election
that's this one no the trump kid oh the
trump kid
yeah junior baron no not barron that's
so
funny is there more is there more photos
is there more photos all right so this
is uh mick isaac this is his shop
in uh delaware definitely see his
identity isn't that kind of like just
wrong
yeah i was gonna say that that's
unethical right if you're if you're a
macbook
owner you're like a doctor you can't be
selling the contents of people's laptops
how is his identity so public isn't he
afraid of getting murdered or something
exactly that's another thing too that
doesn't quite add up here and i i've
been
reading the story i've been trying to
figure out what his motive is so
he states that he's not a political type
although he said he voted for trump in
2016.
okay that's a red flag right everyone
can vote though everyone can vote yes
you could be non-political and still
vote yeah okay so then he recovers this
uh the
the photos and all these things
incriminating photos and he's like
i don't want this in my shop i need to
get it out
so then he goes and says to the fbi i i
made a copy of this
of this content onto my own hard drive
and i'm like wait what so you're you're
you're afraid of this content
being in your vicinity in your
possession
you actually duplicated it and then he's
then he hands the laptop over to the
that guy looks like he sells [ __ ]
crack to hunter
doesn't it look like this sketchiest guy
ever bro
like he's not even trying to not look
sketch the mask
looks he looks fine yeah yeah the master
hat asked it better
oh he told it yeah isn't that a little
bit yeah like a conflict of interest
right like
and then what happened to this guy he
could still run a shop and [ __ ] you know
yeah and he said he did say like he was
afraid for his life he was afraid for
his life that
you know the biden camp will come after
him and have him murdered and whatnot so
let me go public with this
don't get it and show anyone else needs
your computer fix and also your files
shared everywhere else please
yeah so here's like a photo of the
subpoena come on
the command plus command plus command
where's plus how do i do this anthony
there we go boom that's there's a copy
of the subpoena
so uh the fbi fbi has uh uh what legal
legal means to
have this laptop in its uh possession
what
how does that work legally yeah but why
do they need these pictures
i don't know does it help an
investigation
if i could have any picture of hunter
biden it'd be that one
that's a good picture i picked him
covering his nipples in the tub
yeah like just yeah super just chilled
out this is like right in front of a
little vanity set too
oh i thought that was an arcade do you
think he's sending this picture to
somebody
do you think he's just keeping it he's
sending it to girls dude so
i think so this is like the the the
other half of his life bad boy hunter
69 dude but the crack shot has got to be
somebody else like
they're like dude you were so [ __ ]
wasted last night they take that picture
they'll be like look at this [ __ ] and
then they send it to him
or it's like dude he's so wasted and
then they like plant it next to him and
then they take up
oh yeah see that makes sense too all
right
true yeah so there's a lot of sneaky guy
you know
there's a lot of messages that were
found on his laptop as well that
um pretty much yeah and i'm like this is
like really personal stuff but like uh
yeah he's like you know texting his
friends like come over to the hotel
i'm gonna get you [ __ ] up and like you
know typical like normal people
talk but because it's in it's in the
context of a politician's son it feels
like crazier or whatever
yeah um so yeah it does feel like an
invasion of privacy to a certain extent
and then an extent this is a clear
violation of privacy
true but then i guess if you play the
game of politics i mean it seems like
nothing's probably do you think if this
happened
10 years ago like in the 90s do you
think it would be way bigger of a deal
than it is now
yeah big time dude way more i mean
politics has changed so
[ __ ] much desensitizing scandals now
too it's like oh it's not understandable
you're like only crack
okay whatever you know like that's how
that's how i kind of feel kind of really
too
yeah which is the sad part like oh [ __ ]
just crack whatever yeah i was waiting
for you to say something like oh they
found all this porn and it's like kitty
boy
of just like we don't know that it
hasn't been it's a slow rollout so we do
not know
i don't know so it's kind of worrisome
because like we have the whole creepy
biden meme too
now so it's like i don't know how far it
runs your
i don't know it's just uh it's
interesting but um at least he didn't
have a fly land on him in the photo
i just zoom in on that over and over
he's in cream dude
what do you think is going to be the
next thing that they're going to release
oh i don't know i don't know what
it has to be worse and worse because
it's like a dick pic but his dick is
huge so it's actually great
yeah yeah this is how it really starts
really weird that'd be a really weird
look for
rudy giuliani though to release that
that's [ __ ]
weird because then everything he
releases but he shows it but it's on his
wallpaper on his phone
and then hunter biden becomes the next
kim kardashian yeah
one night in hunter yeah oh my god
hunter has stayed quiet about this the
whole entire biden camp has stayed quiet
about this no one's actually said
anything yet
they're like hey wait until we get to
the dick pic that's what they're saying
what about the whole ukrainian [ __ ] no
one's talking about that
the ukrainian thing is uh a a move that
hunter did according to certain proof
here here's an uh here's a screenshot of
an email that he sent to this guy named
vlad vadim
yes and uh so what this email email was
was that he was trying hunter was trying
to get his dad
so joe biden and at this time he was the
vice president to meet this guy
who then they could develop a
relationship in which then uh this guy
is actually this company that um hunter
biden is uh
associated with in the ukraine was being
investigated by the ukrainian government
and so hunter was trying to get joe
biden on board with this camp so that he
could leverage
his power his american power uh to back
the ukrainian government away
from the investigation on this company
so there's a lot about that company
because he gets paid 50 000 a month from
this company
and then something went well and he got
paid
3 million from a russian company for
making the right moves yeah whether i
mean we don't know if it's right or
wrong
it's the the point is i think the reason
why
russia and all this that is because a
lot of people think that
you know one side doesn't deal with
russia at all and traditionally russia
has been our enemy
so it feels weird that you know are
a lot of people tied to politics and and
government
is out there doing business deals with
russia because they've been
traditionally telling us
what an enemy they were so it kind of
glitches people's thoughts
like why the [ __ ] are they doing this
for sure i don't think
i i don't even know if there's any wrong
doing i did check up on the scandal
and um it checks out at least from
investigators that he didn't do anything
right that's also from 2015 yeah like
this that's what this
story coming yeah it's 20 it's five
years in the making this entire story
yeah and so so i think i think what made
it worse though was twitter and facebook
uh censoring it for some reason they
censored it yeah and like if you really
go into the details
of the reason does it seem to be that
incriminating you know unless there's
more to come like how giuliani is there
reasoning as to why social media is
censoring this
uh no so uh who jack jack what's his
face door george whatever yeah
uh he he recently came out and said he
apologizes on behalf of twitter for
censoring it
uh and he didn't really supply a reason
why uh twitter did censorship
yeah exactly so it's just it's just
interesting to see it unfold right now
and then i will leave you with this at
the end of this video
that you know i think hunter biden you
know he's just a person and he has
different facets to him and
another thing that got leaked out was a
uh like
it seems like a vomit writing like like
you know when you just like just wrapped
writing thoughts out he wrote about his
brother beau biden who recently passed
away a couple years back
and it was very hard when i was reading
i kind of like got a little choked up
and i was just like he's hurting from
the inside and i'm just like man this
guy
you know for him to be dealing with that
and then now his dad's in this political
spotlight and then just
to be released it's like it's it's tough
it's a tough situation yeah
playing in a powerful position politics
and all this stuff
it just really there's no privacy and
that's like that for
tomlin in the lannisters you know that's
what jumped out the window
oh yeah because his mom's cersei
lannister like just like this that whole
game is too crazy he's like man [ __ ]
this [ __ ]
jump out the window that's because he's
like just died right now marjorie got
locked up and then
did she die no she didn't die yet
spoiler alert i don't know oh
[ __ ] like 20 years ago now well this is
five years ago not sure fair enough
you